9h59 new york 20 ans après un film est
signé olivier ponthus ce avec nous pour
en parler dans ce premier numéro d'un
monde en doc bruno des linges et
bienvenue et vous êtes vous même un
rescapé des attentats de new york vous
étiez aux quarante septième étage de
l'une des tours vous nous direz
d'ailleurs peut-être si vous vous êtes
reconnu dans certains des témoignages
qu'on a entendu dans ce documentaire
patricia correia bienvenue à vous vous
êtes vice-président de l'association 13
11 15 fraternité vérité qui regroupe les
victimes des attentats du 13 novembre à
paris vous avez vous même perdu votre
fille et le compagnon de votre fils ce
soir là marianne kedia et également avec
nous bien venu vous êtes docteur en
psychologie et psychothérapeute
spécialiste du psycho traumatisme et
vous êtes l'auteur de ce livre penser
les attentats pour ne pas céder à la
peur frédérique calandra bienvenue à
vous également vous êtes délégué
interministériel à l'aide aux victimes
et présidente du centre national de
ressources et de résilience merci à tous
les quatre d'être avec nous bruno des
linges et vous auriez pu vous même faire
partie de ce film vingt ans après ou
est-ce que vous en êtes est ce que ces
vingt dernières années ont été un
parcours du combattant comme on l'entend
dans ce documentaire
oui j'ai été très touché parce ce
reportage parce que ce documentaire
parce qu'il évoque bien ce que nous tous
survivants qui ont été présentés comme
des chanceux d'une certaine manière on
vécu et une souffrance terrible qui est
passé derrière bien sûr la souffrance
des victimes et de leurs familles et
dont on a finalement très peu parlé et
c'est des choses quotidiennes qui sont
des peurs qu'on n'arrive pas à contrôler
des souffrances psychologiques très
intense monte il a fallu des années et
des années à ce
beau pour pouvoir s'en débarrasser donc
je me reconnais complètement dans ce
dans ce documentaire marienne kedia
j'imagine qu'il y a plein de façons de
vivre un tel choc les années qui suivent
sont forcément douloureuses compliquée
avec de l'anxiété de la dépression en
entend de la paranoïa de la culpabilité
aussi pourquoi moi j'ai survécu pourquoi
moi j'ai survécu
documentaire décrit très bien ce que
vivent classiques ont des personnes qui
ont survécu à des attentats d'une telle
ampleur mais pour répondre à votre
question est ce que nécessairement on
vit très mal la réponse est non on
estime par exemple les attentats du
world trade center que 20 à 35% des
victimes ont développé des symptômes
extrêmement sévère à la fois c'est
beaucoup et puis en même temps ça peut
paraître étonnant parce que c'est pas
tant que ça moi je trouve mais pour
autant voilà ça reste parmi les
événements qui sont extrêmement traumato
jeunes et qu'ils vont déclencher un
ensemble de symptômes qu'on que le
documentaire décrit extrêmement bien
notamment le fait de revivre constamment
l'incident initial l'attentât initiale
le fait de
éviter certaines situations qui peuvent
rappeler cet événement là et puis le
fait d'être sur le qui vive en
permanence ce que décrivent aussi
beaucoup de personnes qui témoignent
dans ce documentaire est ce que la pire
des choses c'est le sait le déni on
entend cette femme racontait qu'elle
s'est d'abord réfugié dans le travail et
que tout lui a explosé à la figure des
années plus tard alors ça c'est très
typique de ce qu'on appelle le syndrome
d'évitement c'est à dire que si vous
voulez quand vous avez vécu un événement
de cette ampleur là est aussi grave
tout vous ramène à sa en permanence et
c'est pas comme si vous vous rappeliez
l'événement c'est comme si vous leur
vivier donc avec tout le cortège
d'émotions de sensations extrêmement
désagréable et c'est donc en fait les
gens vont avoir une phobie de leurs
souvenirs traumatiques et vont tout
faire pour pas y penser donc ça peut
être une plongée dans le travail on voit
aussi dans le documentaire consommé de
l'alcool de façon très importante parce
que ça donne le petit coup de massue qui
fait qu'on se déconnecte de ses émotions
ou qu'on pense à autre chose ça c'est
très caractéristiques du syndrome de
stress post traumatique alors il ya ceux
qui y étaient
les victimes directes j'ai envie de dire
des attentats patricia correia est-ce
que vous en tant que proches de victimes
vous vous considérez vous aussi comme
victimes du terrorisme est ce que
d'ailleurs vous avez envie d'être
reconnu comme tel alors c'est ce que je
dis lorsqu'on interroge je ne suis pas
la victime c'est ma fille c'est son
compagnon moi je suis une victime
collatérale avec tout ce que ça
représente
puisque je suis en vie et que je dois
essayer de tenir debout depuis cette
horrible tragédie et c'est tous les
jours c'est le bateau le parcours du
combattant donc c'est vraiment mais le
mot victime je pense qu'il s'adresse
plutôt à ma fille et à son compagnon je
suis une victime collatérale et avec
toute la lourdeur et et nous sommes
déchirés de l'intérieur vous savez
lorsqu'on a perdu un enfant on
culpabilise déjà d'être parti avec avant
avant son enfant puisque ma fille elle
était en pleine santé elle adorait la
vie à la croque à pleines dents donc je
me dis mais encore laura était malade
mais bon c'était pas le cas et je me dis
mais qu'est ce que je fais dans ce dans
ce monde je suis en vie elle n'est plus
voyez il ya plein de choses qui se
mettent les kivu qui vous parcourt le
cerveau qui vous habite au quotidien et
je vais vous dire quelque fois on a les
tripes à vif c'est je reprécise que
votre fille est morte dans les attentats
du 13 novembre à paris évidemment on est
plus il qu'à des attentats du 11
septembre frédérique calandra
on imagine que le rôle de l'état est
très important très vite pour les
victimes ou pour les proches des
victimes
qu'est ce qu'un état qu'est ce que des
autorités publiques peuvent faire gens
me dire dans les premières heures dans
l'urgence dans les premiers jours avant
de parler de la reconstruction sur le
très long terme on y viendra évidemment
mais tout de suite qu'est-ce que des
autorités publiques peuvent faire on en
voit bien sûr des acteurs de la santé
spécialisés des samu mais on a mis en
place l'état français a mis en place ce
qu'on appelle les qu'une cellule
d'urgence médico-psychologique la corse
et la prise en charge du jeune charles
exactement psychologique sur le lieu
même de l'attentât et ça c'est quelque
chose qui
est relativement récent avec des
psychiatres médecins psychiatres
psychologues spécialisés des infirmiers
spécialisés dans la prise en charge et
qui vont accompagner les victimes tout
de suite dé la commission des faits et
ensuite évidemment on mais après la
crise dans la gestion du plus long terme
d accompagnement psychologique
spécialisés marianne kedia qu'est ce qui
se joue dans les premières heures c'est
fondamental de une bonne prise en charge
tout de suite les interventions des
toutes premières heures après un
événement traumatique c'est ce qu'on
appelle des interventions poste
immédiate donc l'enjeu est ce moment là
avant toute chose ça va être de
sécuriser les personnes c'est à dire
qu'on n'est pas vraiment dans la prise
en charge psychologique poussée avec un
intérêt sur les émotions etc c'est
vraiment juste rassurer les personnes
autant que faire se peut les mettre en
contact avec leurs proches et aussi leur
donner des points de repère pour que
eux-mêmes sache si dans les jours qui
viennent ce qui risque de se passer dans
quel état ils risquent d'être et qu'est
ce qui devrait les amener à consulter et
où consulté si la situation se présente
donc vraiment les premières heures c'est
vraiment juste un accompagnement très
léger est aussi un moment de repérage
pour les praticiens parce qu'on peut
voir parfois des personnes qui sont en
état de choc très prononcé et qui sont
donc des personnes très vulnérables à ce
moment là qu'il va falloir surveiller
dans les jours qui viennent bruno des
linges et vous l'avez eue cet
accompagnement dans les heures qui ont
suivi le choc que vous avez vécu non
absolument pas personne n'était prêt aux
états unis à une situation d'une
violence pareil donc il a fallu qu'on se
débrouille tout seul comme on ne pouvait
avec l'accompagnement des gens qui nous
entouraient et et puis porter je dirais
par quelque chose qui
était particulièrement unique à sept
attentats du 11 septembre c'est que
immédiatement la nation américaine
s'est dressée révolte et faisant preuve
d'un patriotisme extraordinaire d'une
générosité
d'une solidarité unique dans son
histoire qui ont fait que tout à chacun
on s'est senti
presque contraint d'une certaine manière
d'être à la hauteur donc il s'agissait
pas pour nous de considérer
ce qui ce qui n'allait pas en nous il
n'était pas question il s'agissait de
d'être à la hauteur pour une survivre
pour immédiatement se mettre à la tâche
et reconstruire et au fond se préoccuper
de nous plus tard et on a tout de suite
appris à vivre avec ce stress c'est à
dire vous donner une image pendant des
semaines et des semaines pour ce qui me
concerne
j'étais convaincu que les tours étaient
encore debout donc je regardais au bout
de l'île de manhattan et je n'arrivais
pas à comprendre c'était juste de
l'incompréhension qui qui joue bien tout
simplement
le fait que quand j'ai été engloutis
dans le tordeur dans les gravats et
la violence du nuage qui s'est abattue
sur nous en l'espace de quelques
instants tout est devenu noir qu'une
nuit et cette noirceur de la nuit
accompagné du silence total qui s'est
emparée de la ville parce que l'air ne
vibrait plus quand il était épais et
bien on fait que mon inconscient a cru
qu'il était que j'étais mort tout
simplement et pendant des semaines et
des semaines
je me promenais dans la rue et
je
voyais le soleil je sais pas un taxi une
jolie si le message rentrée par mes sens
mais du fond de mes tripes sortait le
message inverse me disant mais c'est pas
possible puisque tu es mort et donc
inconsciemment donc à chaque seconde
d'une certaine manière si je m'exposais
à la vie j'avais un fusible dans la tête
qui explosait en me disant
c'est pas possible au message que tu
reçois c'est non ça n'existe pas et donc
ça a été très très difficile à vivre
mais on s'est habitué et c'est seulement
après quand j'ai senti que qu' il
fallait que je fasse quelque chose qui
avait deux choses que je n'arrivais pas
à avaler que j'ai été voir une
psychologue qui m'a aidé à
régurgiter si vous voulez c'est ce
qu'ils avaient du mal à passer
alors ensuite ça a été un long processus
de 2,2 qui est passé notamment par
l'écriture puisque j'en ai la passion et
c'est l'écriture d'un livre
littéraire sur ce sujet qui m'a permis
de
véritablement me débarrasser de toute la
grande boîte que j'avais ouvert aux
grandes mois et dans laquelle j'avais
emmagasiné soit des images soient des
souvenirs soient des émotions soit les
terrains
vous avez mis là soigneusement pour les
isoler respect encore quelques instants
dans le ressenti en france après les
attentats du bataclan antoine l'iris qui
avait perdu sa femme a publié une lettre
ouverte sur facebook qui a connu un
retentissement médiatique très fort
peut-être que vous en souvenez elle
était intitulé cette lettre vous n'aurez
pas ma haine et pourtant la haine
certains rescapés du documentaire l'ont
ressenti ils l'expriment et ils
l'assument on écoute en l'instant et je
vous fait réagir juste après
[Musique]
deux
figures de proue
patricia correia est ce que vous vous
l'avez ressenti cette haine est est ce
que vous assuriez le média belge fait
franche avec vous oui j'ai eu de la
haine j'ai encore de beaucoup de colère
et je me disais
enfin moi même puisque bon je parle je
parle souvent ma fille à sa photo je lui
dis quelquefois quand elle repose à
lisbonne quelquefois quand je suis
devant la petite chapelle où elle repose
ça m'arrive de du relais devant devant
devant auprès d'elle parce que je suis
complètement dévasté je vous le cache
pas je et puis si je n'avais pas de
colère vraiment de la colère vis-à-vis
de sa mémoire c'est que ce serait
indécent c'est comme ça je ressens mais
vous savez chaque cas est différent
je vais je chaque cas est unique on ne
peut pas un enfant c'est ses tripes
alors
je suis désolé de le dire mais voilà
c'est marianne qui est dit est ce qu
elle est importante cette colère aussi
peut-être pour se reconstruire alors je
pense qu'elle signe clairement un
attachement
par exemple la personne
décédée ou un sursaut aussi de face au
manque de contrôle qu'on a pu avoir
quand on a vécu
non traumatisant après moi j'ai aussi
accompagné beaucoup de victimes je me
rappelle notamment de mes patients au
monde de la mort de kadhafi qui avait
été lynché je suis j'ai des patients qui
avaient été victimes de torture qui
était demandeur d'asile et beaucoup
avaient été extrêmement choqué parce que
et quelques uns le dit d'ailleurs dans
le documentaire 1 il pense que la
justice peut être une meilleure solution
qui correspond mieux aux valeurs
que même défendent et deux parce que
légitimer la violence en fait comme ça
peut l'être ça peut être fait dans
certaines de ces situations là ça valide
quelque part que la violence est une
arme légitime donc que la violence que
même en subit peut être légitime et
d'une manière ou d'une autre donc on a
on a vraiment tout le panel de réactions
je pense pas la colère c'est une chose
dans le documentaire on les zombies sont
plus de l'ordre de la vengeance et donc
on peut aller surtout ce spectre là je
pense de façon très très habituel mais
l'inquiétante j'imagine cette colère et
cette haine frédérique calandra quand on
se place du côté du pouvoir public
encore une fois que les individus
ressens de la colère de la rage de la
haine c'est absolument je crois un
processus tout à fait normal chacun
d'entre nous évidemment au premier chef
les victimes ou les victimes indirectes
les proches des victimes mais n'importe
quel citoyen ensuite c'est le rôle d'un
état démocratique de dire
le vous n'aurez pas mal moi j'ai mis du
temps à le digérer un j'étais maire du
20e arrondissement quand il ya eu la
prise d'otage de l'hyper cacher quand
vous passez une journée à attendre de
savoir combien vous aurez de mort le
soir dont des enfants réfugiés dans une
chambre froide je peux vous dire que
vous finissez la journée aussi
heureusement je n'avais pas une arme à
ce moment là pour dire les choses
clairement mais justement le rôle de
l'état et rôle de la justice en
particulier c'est de dire que la justice
ce n'est pas la vence et surtout ce que
cherchent les terroristes à nous
terroriser mais surtout à combattre nos
sociétés démocratiques et à nous
transformer en bulles de haine
précisément donc évidemment le rôle de
la puissance publique c'est de prendre
de la distance et de transformer le
chagrin la colère là ge en des décisions
à la fois démocratique mais aussi de
protection de ses citoyens donc il faut
être à la fois il faut rejeter ce que
veulent faire de nous les terroristes
tout en étant lucide c'est à dire en les
combattant férocement mais avec les
armes des démocraties voilà et nous ne
deviendrons pas comme ce que ce que
j'espère ce que voulait dire monsieur
leiris et vous me tendent un miroir mais
je ne me laisserait pas piéger je ne
deviendrai pas comme vous en revanche et
je voulais le dire à madame correia en
particulier il faut savoir que en ce
moment des études sont menées notamment
par un chercheur universitaire qui
s'appelle denis peschanski qui est bien
connu puisque et voilà et qui est un
type formidable par ailleurs et qui fait
des recherches avec des psychologues des
psychiatres et des neuro psychologue sur
les conséquences psychiques et
somatiques sur les parents des victimes
et il est en train de démontrer que les
traumatismes les psycho traumatisme chez
les parents des enfants qui étaient au
bataclan ou aux terrasses sont presque
supérieurs à ceux des victimes directes
c'est à dire que le fait d'attendre des
nouvelles de quelqu'un on l'a vu aussi
avec les victimes les parents des jeunes
gens qui ont été tués au niger le fait
d'attendre des nouvelles à côté du
téléphone de ne pas savoir de de penser
les pour les victimes du niger ça a été
atroce parce que les photos
des jeunes gens tués ont circulé sur
twitter et d'ailleurs des hommes et des
femmes politiques se sont
particulièrement déshonoré à ce moment
là en les utilisant comme des armes de
propagande et ça c'est absolument
monstrueux est totalement contre les
principes de nos démocraties et donc on
sait qu' il y a des dégâts
psychologiques très fort chez les
parents et c'est pour ça que même si
vous êtes effectivement on la justice a
du mal à définir on dit victime
indirecte proches des victimes pour
autant vous êtes une victime quand même
parce que ce qui ce dont on vous a privé
enfin votre vie ne sera plus jamais
pareil al rai qu'avant voilà ma vie à
écouler mais voilà complètement
quelqu'un quelqu'un de façon illégale
monstrueuse décidez de vous priver de
votre vie telle qu'elle était avant que
sa une société démocratique ne saurait
l'admettre alors la haine est plutôt
stérile mais qu'on ressent une violente
colère je trouve que dans un état
démocratique c'est somme toute assez
sain alors on va se projeter un petit
peu sur la sur la suite des mois parfois
des années après l'attentât vient tout
de même l'heure de la reconstruction là
aussi chacun trouve son propre chemin
dans le documentaire on découvre là
encore cette femme qui trouve du
réconfort et un peu de sérénité auprès
des chevaux ça nous a marqué on regarde
un extrait on en parle après
le joué par andy serkis
hnd orbit racing team et nathalie
bruneau des langes et quelle a été votre
façon à vous de vous reconstruire
plusieurs étapes dans la reconstruction
il ya eu le livre dont je vous ai parlé
qui m'a permis d'explorer toutes les
toutes les vraies choses qui m'habitait
dont la dont certainement le sentiment
de revanche la violence puisque mourier
donné à l'époque ben laden entre les
mains j'ai eu je les vis et ray
et tellement la souffrance avait été au
riz et puis il ya eu une image qui m'a
vraiment projeté dans le
dans l'avenir je dirais c'est
lorsque j'ai vu l'échographie
de de celui qui allait devenir mon fils
donc
se paie tous vivent toute cette
tendresse dans laquelle je me projetais
la naissance de cet enfant a
certainement fait passer un cap
important
dans la reconstruction
parce que
il me détourner de moi même d'une
certaine manière donc
il s'agissait plus
égoïstement de moi même mais bien de
survivre pour quelqu'un et je dois dire
que ça a été une étape
extrêmement importante
et puis ensuite c'est des milliers de
des centaines au moins deux petits
détails de la vie qui font qu'on passe
des états peut
retrouver le goût des bonnes choses
retrouvez
laisser le temps
arrondir les angles de ski et ski ski
sans nos peurs et qui
qui nous habite quand même très très
longtemps du temps patrice à correia
comment vous vous avez entamé une forme
de reconstruction santé qu'on puisse se
repeindre une forme et la construction
jeu
non alors moi je consulte que depuis
deux mois déjà pour commencer pourquoi
pourquoi pas avant bien j'ai rencontré
quelques psychiatres au début et puis ça
fonctionnait pas on recevait un quart
d'heure après on prenait congé enfin
j'en ai rencontré deux ou trois donc
j'ai laissé tomber je me suis mise à
fond dans l'association que nous avons
créée en janvier 2016
et puis surtout
dans le dans la commission mémorielle
puisque
ma bataille actuellement mon combat
c'est la mémoire ne jamais oublier
que des
toutes ces personnes qui ont été
arrachés à la vie et tous ceux qui sont
blessés tout ce qu'ont vécu des dessins
des scènes de guerre enfin cesser c'est
tellement terrible pour la mémoire doit
enfin c'est ce qui me fait tenir debout
actuellement oui c'est vraiment le
combat que je mène vous avez
vous êtes que vous êtes accompagné
succès dans un peu compliqué c'est un
peu compliqué c'est très long au niveau
du fonds de garantie ya vraiment des
lacunes alors évidemment est ce que
l'aide financière est quelque chose
aussi de fondamental or il faut savoir
que l'aide financière et je le précise
chaque fois cette aide financée parce
que vous savez la population en général
il imagine que cette financière c'est
pour la perte d'un enfant alors non
surtout pas c'est pour les personnes qui
ont perdu un enfant ou un proche ou un
mari sont très fragilisées donc ne
peuvent elles sont plus elle non plus la
même la même force elles ont besoin d'un
un certain confort peut être certaines
ne sont plus capables de prendre des
transports d'autres ont besoin d'une
aide ménagère il ya d'autres ont perdu
leur petit commerce parce qu'ils étaient
à deux et que les deux filles anna sur
les deux qui n'est plus ne sont plus en
état de travailler absolument les gens
sont très affaiblis donc il faut
vraiment que que la population mais je
vous le dis parce que je sais de quoi je
parle ne pense pas qu une
perte une vie n'a pas de prix et cette
somme qu'on va vous qu'on va vous donner
ça va être pour vous aider vous
accompagne et vous et votre cas
personnel en mon cas personnel moi je
n'ai pas encore été expertisée ce sera à
l'automne prochain d'accord mais j'ai
des cas des gens qui sont vraiment mes 6
ans après vous n'avez toujours pas été
expertisé non c'est très long c'est très
très long pour tous c'est très long vous
rendez compte on va arriver à 6 ans au
bout de six ans rien n'est réglé alors
il faut il faut vraiment que tout soit
mis en place pour que les choses
avancent vite frédérique calandra
que répondre à cela cette lenteur des
aides cette lenteur administrative alors
déjà je répondrais hausse avec le fonds
de garantie des victimes de terrorisme
et d'autres infractions pénales
puisqu'il indemnise également depuis
quelques années des victimes
d'infractions pénales graves notamment
de viols en particulier de tentative de
meurtre externe le fgti existe depuis on
va dire il est il a été fondé par
françoise au jet-ski qui était la
présidente de sos attentats qu'ils
étaient victimes de l'attentât du grand
véfour dans lequel son mari est mort
réelle elle a été gravement blessé et
est là avec le premier ministre jacques
chirac de l'époque qu'ils ont décidé de
prendre en main de soutenir les victimes
d'actes de terrorisme le fjt y étant et
je dirais en construction permanente
donc il il tente je suis membre de son
conseil d'administration ainsi que
françoise au des skis et d'autres
représentants de victimes il essaye de
s'améliorer en permanence il a il a des
faiblesses encore des lacunes j'en suis
langue et encore j'en suis d'accord mais
alors sachez quand même je vais le
défendre et faire l'avocat du diable si
j'ose dire que il est quand même donné
en exemple au niveau européen puisque
nous sommes le seul pays à disposer de
ce type de doughty d'indemnisation alors
pourquoi c'est son fonctionnement à un
emploi de séjour des personnes on n'en
revient pas de lens khalifa on n'enquête
pas c'est une procédure d'indemnisation
amiable cette procédure d'indemnisation
elle suppose une évaluation des
préjudices ça ça ça existait d'ailleurs
avant enfin à côté du fgti ça existe
dans d'autres fonds d'indemnisation
comme l'oniam
quand on est dans une procédure
d'appréciation individualiser le
principe c'est
d'individus d'indemniser la personne est
d'essayer de faire en sorte qu'à la fin
du processus sa vie soit le plus proche
possible de ce qu'elle était avant c'est
le principe de la réparation intégrale
du préjudice
alors intégral c'est symbolique parce
que alors qu'est ce qu'on fait il ya
deux solutions ou vous faites vous
barrez misé tout et vous dites je veux
dire des choses terribles mais vous
dites la perte d'un enfant s'étend de
milliers d'euros la perte d'une main la
perte d'une jambe s'étendent et vous
faites un barème ou comme l'ont demandé
les associations de victimes et les
avocats à juste titre vous êtes dans
l'appréciation individualisé par exemple
et je vais rentrer dans des détails oui
mais rapidement d'où la piquante le fait
que ça prenne vous avez été au bataclan
quand vous êtes sorti au bout de
quelques minutes du bataclan évidemment
vous n'aurez pas les mêmes traumatismes
vous serez traumatisé mais vous n'aurez
pas les mêmes traumatismes que quand
vous êtes resté deux heures dans la
fosse donc quand vous dites
individualisé c'est du cas par cas c'est
du cas par cas là donc c'est forcément
long alors après les victimes ont le
choix entre accepter dans la procédure à
dia amiable dès le début une
indemnisation qui est proposée par le
fjt ils peuvent la discuter ou alors y
rentrer dans une procédure avec des
médecins experts qu'ils sont des
médecins pour le somatiques lecorne
aussi pour le psychologique et la il y à
des améliorations il ya eu des cas de
médecins par exemple les victimes nous
ont dit fort peu empathique qui ont posé
des questions de façon très maladroite
voire ward dur et mécaniques qui ont su
rajouter du traumatisme et j'ai commencé
la question je les pose et à marianne
kedia alors c'est un processus qui
finalement peut-être ajoute de la
lourdeur et de la peine alors que c'est
censé aider les victimes il ya un
paradoxe immense là on est exactement ce
que j'aurais des crimes tout à l'heure
c'est à dire que quand on est traumatisé
on fait tout pour éviter de penser à
l'événement traumatique et donc
forcément une expertise ça vous oblige à
vous replonger dans ses souvenirs là et
a fortiori
quand le regard de la personne qui
interroge je n'ai pas bienveillant n'est
pas très empathique vraiment devenir
catastrophique est vraiment mon bois des
patients comme ça qu'ils qui ont des
espèces de rebond en fait du stress post
traumatique suite à des expertises ça
peut arriver oui et quid de la justice
marianne kedia il faut que la justice
passe ça aussi ça fait partie du
processus de reconstruction c'est
essentiel pour une victime ou pour des
proches de victimes alors c'est une
question très compliquée je trouve au
niveau psychologique parce qu'en
pratique on sait que les procédures de
justice généralement vont faire flamber
les symptômes post traumatiques donc
parfois on a des améliorations puis
souvent le processus de justice prend
beaucoup de temps donc on a le temps
d'avancé clairement avec les passions
est en fait un procès va venir
remuer tout ça parfois réouvrir les
peler et évidemment mais pas toujours
avec une issue positive pour la victime
à la fin du procès donc c'est très en
dirait long personnellement moi je ne
pousse jamais mes patients à porter
plainte par exemple après des agressions
sexuelles etc c'est eux qui décideront
d'ici on discute des avantages et des
inconvénients mais on sait que sur le
plan psychologique c'est pas du tout du
gâteau c'est pas gagné c'est pour ça
qu'il ya des victimes qui ne se porte
pas partie civile sur mon procès charlie
hebdo à ce qu'il n'y arrive pas je pose
la question parce qu'effectivement il ya
ce procès des attentats du 13 novembre
2015 comment vous voyez cette étape pour
vous pour votre histoire alors moi cette
étape je la vois elle est nécessaire si
vous voulez parce que ce procès est
nécessaire on doit juger ces personnes
qui ont arraché la vie qui ont blessé
des gens mais je n'en attends pas grand
chose
pour moi le procès il va servir ce
qu'ils soient transmis dans nos livres
d'histoire transmis à nous nos futures
générations et ne jamais oublier ce qui
s'est passé c'est exactement ce que j'en
attends et puis il est nécessaire
puisque jerem exprimés à la barre parce
que j'ai des choses à dire et
en main en allant m'exprimer à la base
je ferais briller la mémoire de ma fille
et de son compagnon voilà c'est
simplement ce que j'en attends mais je
veux je vous dis honnêtement gérer pas
tous les jours parce que j'ai assisté
aux proches aux procédés logeur j'étais
complètement vidé j'étais très très mal
j'y suis allé tous les jours j'aurais
jamais dû faire ça c'est une étape très
très dur et d'ailleurs je nous le disons
à nos adhérents foot qu'ils soient
prudents parce que c'est d'une violence
extrême je peux vous dire qu'il y aura
des rivières de larmes je peux vous le
dire bruno des linges et comment vous
voyez cette étape de la justice elle
vous semble capital est ce que pour vous
les attentats du 11 septembre il ya eu
justice
la justice n'intervient jamais dans une
histoire de de terrorisme il ya beaucoup
d'injustice qui reste très très vivant
nous dont je redis
que nous sommes considérés comme des
chanceux puisque nous avons échappé à la
mort et c'est vrai on a eu beaucoup de
chance
mais en même temps tous toute la vie qui
a été bouleversée chamboulé en partie
détruite
sans l'aide de personne parce que
j'entendais madame la déléguée
interministérielle
parler des dispositifs qui existent moi
je n'ai bénéficié de retient absolument
rien mais à feu lui je me débrouille
tout seul
bon donc je considère là pour le coup
que c'est une véritable injustice
la justice l'institution judiciaire
dans le cas du 2e de l'attentât du 11
septembre
ont rayé le documentaire l'apport d'un
puisqu'on on parle de ben laden
supprimée et et comment un certain
nombre de victimes regrettent qu'il
n'ait pas été traduits en justice moi je
me rappelle très bien ma réaction ce
matin d'apprendre j'ai découvert la mort
de ben laden
j'étais fou de joie des années plus tard
et en même temps me sentant coupable de
de me réjouir de la mort d'un homme donc
tout ça est très compliqué et c'est vrai
que la justice c'est quand même le lieu
de l'expression c'est le lieu de l'
équilibre et c'est toujours à mon avis
la solution a favorisé par ce que il n'y
a pas de il n'y a pas de recette miracle
pour aider les victimes non dans ce dans
ce domaine si la suppression des lignes
b et d et aux auteurs des attentats
leurs règles au patin moi je me rappelle
très bien de cette ceux du sentiment de
culpabilité 1,2 me réjouir de la mort
d'un homme
ça fait pas partie de mon échelle de
valeur alors que
j'aurais été capable effectivement de le
trucider au lendemain des attentats et à
ce titre là moi j'avais été très étonnée
d'une sollicitation que j'avais reçu de
la part de écoles de saint cyr
coëtquidan
qui m'avaient appelée pour témoigner
justement des réactions on avait à la
suite d'un
d'un attentat et pour prévenir ces
élèves officiers donc iront encore et
des élèves des situations similaires sur
les champs de bataille et qu'il fallait
pas réagir avec la haine au ventre parce
qu'elles étaient très mauvaises je
conseillais et on s'arrêtera sur ces
mots merci infiniment pour tous vos
témoignages merci à tous d'avoir
participé à ce premier numéro d'un monde
en doc avant de vous quitter je vous
propose juste quelques ouvrages qui vous
permettront d'approfondir ce sujet votre
livre marianne kedia penser les
attentats que je rappelle journal d'un
rescapé du bataclan être historien et
victimes d'attentats de christophe
naudin il nous reste les mots après le
bataclan dialogue entre le père d'une
victime et celui d'un terroriste de
georges salines et s dynamie moore et si
ton âme en partant de philomène
petitjean merci encore à tous et à
toutes je vous ai tout dit c'est la fin
de cette émission vous pouvez évidemment
la retrouver en replay sur notre site
publicsenat.fr on se retrouve très vite
pour un nouveau numéro sur public sénat
[Musique]